acabou por ser uma coisa lá fora e eu
vou falar muito rápido porque o quadro
na linha tipo alguma coisa que eu eu
tava tirar um café
eu não saí não há explicação é o
seguinte se desconfia que o vídeo do
tabuleiro ouija tem como símbolo a merda
que monstro tipo que foi um toca à noite
eu não sei se tem a ver mas eu to
falando a tocar mais agora num barulho
aconteceu e fora e por que eu não fiz
vídeo antes mostrando boa pessoal nos
traga este tipo de coisas paranormais
mim e eu não sei até que ponto é que foi
que o pessoal diz que foi com o pessoal
diz que a verdade médio não quero me
manter muito nisso eu não quero estar a
mostrar as coisas de você estar em
constante comenta dizer é fake mim eu
tenho evitado e somar 5 mas não vai
passar a dor aguda quando se uma cena a
minha frente e eu vou gravar portanto só
eu não sei como é que estimula a faca em
câmera do iphone eu acho que parar né
eu entendo como vocês podem ver está
tudo escuro aqui fora e agora eu to
foquinho pegado e o que provoca o iphone
está inflacionando stephan schuster aí
eu faço aqui é de uma redação que tenho
aqui no estúdio eu já tinha aberto
porque eu acho que não foi nada aqui
tudo bem aqui ó
só que eu eu tenho este sistema dispara
luz de spotlight o [ __ ] meu bloqueio
foi este aqui eu não sei se é
coincidência que está a passar mas não
deve ser nada mas mesmo assim eu tô
filmado só pra ter viu mesmo porque eu
sei que vocês curtam de lista
portanto mesmo que não aconteça nada eu
estou filmado sempre um vídeo do extra
não é e da viúva sei que vocês gostam
vivo entrevistas que fiz e nunca fez nem
mesmo que afetou ainda tentei entender
que um pan depois nem pestanejaram assim
eu e tão muito agressivo e não sei que é
completamente impossível não espero k é
provável que isso tenha que ir sozinho
porque estava na boca e distribuir funk
estilo do que está explorando o dia tudo
de deus isto para filmar 15 de manhã eu
estava assim o dia todo isso que uma
noite de domingo
estranho isso foi o que aconteceu eu
tava tirar o café e ouvir isto
isso acontecer de novo se deu o luxo no
brasileiro longe eu quero ver se tem
alguma coisa aqui é obstruída catarina
ela costuma fazer os vídeos aqui com uma
faca porque vai né maior do meu estúdio
e aqui temos deveres delas coisa é
carlos aquela minha pergunta se ele
morrer de medo eu sou eu que procurei
baterista e você está aqui a seleção que
está patente com nós guardamos as coisas
que a gente não quer caixas luto muito
bem tenho de coisas velhas catarina tem
que expõe justo eu tenho aqui caixas
como parceira antiga tem muita coisa que
o daee o tempo fica com muito medo nós
temos aí já estava tudo muito escuro tem
uma dúzia de fora porque ele é parte de
fora da loja e os seguranças já dá na
califórnia a fazer sua ronda de novo
visual foi dessa quinta a minha roupa
eu estou com muito medo aqui parece está
tudo vai a este fórum só estou falando
tá sem tocar e não sei porque eles
terminal
não sei se está a dar um está a
funcionar e não sei mas vou tentar nadar
eu fazia e supostamente já tratava
quando inventa a postura portanto eu não
sei a quem protestou fone esquilo às
vezes toca toca é meu eu toca aqui tem
um moda que o comando da net né
vou mostrar aqui canalha que o tablado
não têm muito medo já em cima de um scan
sua tarifa toca eu estou a tentar
perceber agora com vocês
dono de um dos garotos porque não é
muito barulho aqui nesta sala
olha aqui com coisas de pessoas na fil
cá eu já não consigo andar aqui tem um
parque antigo estatuto coisas da
catarina nenhum piano caixa de uma
guitarra
tem muita coisa vem daqui que é
professora e não sei mais que o 1 x 1
para daqui um ano isso nada claro por
filmar um novo parece nada à menina por
dia por ser uma coisa não só para te viu
uma janela mexe não aconteça nunca vou
sair daqui 30 do estatuto é um momento
muito medo eu odeio isso prometo a meus
pais e meu filho morrendo lei e é meu
deus eu estou aqui sozinho isolou a
ninguém já foi para casa porque já teve
uma noite né
portanto eu estou aqui sozinho o que dá
ainda mais medo já que o setor é lula o
pc está tudo arrumado porque elas figura
a preta sobre tudo o que chega dela o
filme eu tenho um olha que o boneco não
vamos embora
embora ande mar
ok tá tudo no trabalho tiver aqui alguma
coisa cria um sinal e pedro pinto no
braço começa a subir área porque ainda
brinca com essas coisas porque porque
quer mostrar porque quer ter
visualizações mas não levamos fronteira
esta coisa tenha um murro e [ __ ] seu
canal não é pois dar que brincar mais
com estas coisas brinca
aí que o suplemento muito medo a cena
mais estranha é que eu acho que todos os
grupos como a noite são daqui
agora eu não saí cedo os tubos que está
tudo bem mas todo arrebentado eu não sei
se dois tons que tomam construído já tão
velho eu não sei se do ar condicionado
porque às vezes eu ouvi dentro faz bem
para o olho não sei se aí eu não sei se
são pessoas que estão do outro lado eu
não sei mas que vem daqui de julho vai
meu e isto fone eu ainda tenho que ver
onde a questão do meu pai melhor porque
eu tenho medo não tem receio da lei há
nenhum em falar que eu tenha bateria
está sem vida
então toca com o brasil já venceu só uma
coisa que eu não entendo é porque
treinei da guarda as coisas não temos
aqui um instrumento muito medo esse
piano foi o filme orgulho
o técnico é brilho e brilho da câmara
outra faca um espírito muito medo
nesse pacto antigo [ __ ]
gostava de ver o que tem dentro o seu
não não o barco chiu o barco porque só
eu não vou brincar eu não vou brincar
não venham dizer que esse cara aí falei
que eu não estou a brincar - aquela
merda michel eu vou pra casa eu voltar
pra casa foram se você ler o show vocês
eu não tenho no braço foi dar foco à dir
e vivo terá câmeras para eu vir a câmera
eu juro que eu espero que não seja eu
juro que eu vi um barco cheio mesmo eu
não vou brincar meu eu ouvi o barulho
cheiro
só vou embora para casa vou ligar uma
velha amiga para explicar a situação e
espero que tenha apanhado bem mas foi
dessa manhã em itu
amanhã vou postar um vídeo meu e folhas
para aqueles que disseram que isto fique
bem isso aconteceu agora a minha faca em
frente e que não faz vídeos foi colocar
e quando é funk quando inspirado quando
é copiado e o digo que na hora do
desfile bem que assim é meu é [ __ ]
porque eu nem se estender com o
tabuleiro ouija eu não acredito em
religião eu não acredito em espírito e
não cliquem [ __ ] nenhuma
acho que acontecem coisas acontecem e
agora até a faca em manhã porque eu vou
eu vou me embora ainda bem que os tons
erros a deus eu vou pra casa canais você
não gostou do vídeo eu morri